Ever wondered how to make heavy cream?
Here's how I do it.
I start off with some raw milk.
This is full fat raw milk straight from the cow.
I just filtered this milk for a milk screen and put it in the fridge.
By the next day,
the heavy cream has all risen to the top
and it's separated from the milk
and I could just scoop it out.
There are several ways to remove the heavy cream from the top of
the milk. You can scoop it out like this.
This is my favourite way to do it.
You could use a Turkey baster to suck the milk on the off the top,
or you could use,
like, one of those big glass milk dispensers
with a little tap on the bottom
and you could slowly let the milk drain from the bottom
and then you're just left with heavy cream.
So I'm trying to scoop just the cream,
but sometimes I'm gonna scoop a little bit of the milk.
Um, you have the heavy, thick cream on top and then you have just, like,
what I would say, like double triple cream,
and then you have, like,
single cream on the bottom of that,
and then you have milk under that, which is still full fat milk.
So once you let all those different types of cream
sit in the refrigerator overnight
again in another jar,
the heaviest cream will then rise the top
and there you Have your heavy cream